the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has now announced that he
won't be seeking immunity from
prosecution in his corruption case and
he made the announcement in Washington
that's where he's been discussing a
Donald Trump's Middle East peace plan to
be unveiled later today
Netanyahu's main rival Benny Ganz has
also been there he's now on a flight
back to Israel let's talk about the
breaking news from Israel in return
Yahoo withdrawing his immunity request
with a kiva elder he's a columnist at
the owl Monitor he's joining us live
from Tel Aviv is sky thanks very much
for your time with us on al-jazeera so
Akiva elder the reports seem to suggest
that Netanyahu didn't really have the
votes anyways in the Knesset to win this
fight later on today so why do you think
that he would drew his request at this
particular time there's a few reasons
first of all Netanyahu hates to be the
loser he once was quoted as saying I
always get what I want
he wanted the immunity and he wasn't
able to get it he was hoping that maybe
the meeting with Trump with guns the
head of the Opposition next to him which
didn't happen as you know during they
met with the president separately that
maybe the president will be a kind of a
matchmaker and they will end up the
three of them coming out of the White
House shaking hands and going for a
unity government and with no need even
for the March elections but guns who
doesn't have a lot of experience in
politics was smart enough not to fall
into this trap and he made it clear that
he's going back to his or right back to
Israel in order to vote against the
immunity at the other hand Netanyahu
also likes to come up as the victim that
the Knesset s we we know as you just
mentioned the rain he had no chances so
he could say that there is a plot of the
politicians they didn't really intend to
look
to the facts and judge him fairly so I
think that he this was his best way to
come out from this I keep it elder yeah
what does he actually gain from this
request from withdrawing his request
because now then this paves the way for
a trial and he's indicted on three
corruption cases yes but he doesn't have
the majority in the Knesset to get the
immunity so it was just you know a cheap
shot at trying that was very transparent
to gain few more weeks and it didn't
look very presidential so to speak to go
through the Knesset the humiliation and
every day again until the elections to
catch the headlines with the corruption
at first so I think that now he's
looking at the elections he is hoping
that the deal of the century will hijack
the headlines and instead of the
immunity process in the Knesset and here
he can lead with his slogans that you
know this is a one-time opportunity it's
an historical movement bla bla bla and
the people some people I think the
people on the floating boats that guns
wants to move to his side will probably
many of them will buy this and what do
you think happens next I mean any
indication you're getting that he'll
actually be in court before the upcoming
is really election and also another
question for you can an indicted prime
minister let's say he is indicted can he
then form a government if he wins the
election well the Supreme Court asked
this question they asked him and I've
said this question and they said that
it's too early it's a theoretical
question but when push comes to shove
and he will have the majority and ask
the president for the mandate the
president has the power to decide
because it there is no precedent to
- this of the president will have to
decide whether the an indicted person
can get this mandate if he does it will
still be appealed - it will go back to
the Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
will probably make a very clear judgment
that as you you mentioned it's not
really democratic and not really honest
to give an invited member of knesset the
power to form a government and what will
happen now is that the Attorney General
will submit the indictments to the court
they will the they will probably hold
the process until after the elections so
but yes it may be theoretically we may
be in the position that Netanyahu and
you know it takes time until you form a
government after the elections because
of the coalition you need to form a
contest that we will seal Prime Minister
spending few hours in court and then go
to the office and make decisions about
peace and war rights okay interesting
yeah very interesting okay a kiva Eldar
we thank you very much for speaking to
us from Tel Aviv Thank you very